former Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
is speaking publicly about what led to
his firing in March by President Trump
CBS News political contributor Bob
Schieffer interviewed Tillerson in
Houston last night at a dinner to
benefit MD Anderson Cancer Center
Tillerson said the greatest foreign
threats are China's rising influence and
what he called a belligerent Russia he
also talked about the president how
would you describe Donald Trump well
most of you probably know know some of
this but I had never met Donald Trump
until the day he asked me to be
Secretary of State he acts on his
instincts in some respects that looks
like impulsiveness but it's not his
intent to act on impulse I think he
really is trying to act on his instincts
it was challenging for me coming from
the disciplined highly process-oriented
Exxon Mobil Corporation to go to work
for a man who is pretty undisciplined
doesn't doesn't like to read doesn't
read briefing reports doesn't doesn't
like to get into the details of a lot of
things but rather just kind of says look
this is what I believe and you can try
to convince me otherwise but most of the
time you're not going to do that how did
your relationship go off the rails well
I think part of it was obviously we are
starkly different in our Styles we did
not have a common value system when the
president would say well here's what I
want to do and here's how I want to do
it and I'd have to say to him well mr.
president I understand what you want to
do but you can't do it that way it
violates the law it violates the treaty
you know he got really frustrated I
didn't know how to conduct my affairs
with him any other way than in a very
straightforward fashion and I think he
grew tired of me being the guy every day
that told him you can't do that
and let's talk about what we can do it's
very very interesting well it is
interesting interesting or jaw-dropping
one of the two Wow yeah I mean he goes
on to say new he's proud of his
government service he would return he
says if the President act but I mean
what he said there sometimes he told the
president it violates the law it
violates the treaty he got frost state
was frustrated by that and they didn't
share a common set of values well the
values word is the one that's most
interesting because the others are
stylistic differences this way of
behaving Tillerson has his but when you
say that you don't share a value system
for a guy who used to be on the board of
the Boy Scouts you're suggesting a
fundamental disconnect with the way the
American government is supposed to
operate that's an extraordinary claim
was it and remind me was it Rex
Tillerson who said that that had been
reported that he had called the
president a [ __ ] yes leapin [ __ ] yeah
but he also spoke as an executive of a
publicly traded company you know
following protocol following procedures
reading your briefings that's all things
that he'd been used to for decades when
you have a fiduciary responsibility to
the stockholders just in some ways a
president has a responsibility to the
voters large democracy that's named here
to talk so Kennedy I do wonder was did
he know that he was being recorded him
oh yeah yeah yeah Thank You Moshe didn't
know I talked to Bob before he did okay
you knew that this was gonna be his
first public comments interesting the
reading your brief knowing the details
asking questions all that are attributes
that we're all ascribed to George
Herbert Walker Bush over the last days
just in that reminder